thank goodness people are exploiting
Eric about buying things from it by
investing in it by employing people in
it and the worst thing that would happen
is if people's decide to stop exploiting
Africa hi I'm Zach Weiss molar for
reason TV we're here with leon Lowe
author policy analyst and executive
director of the free-market foundation a
think tank based in South Africa Leon
thank you very much for talking to us
smart he's a dick some of your earliest
political involvement was in South
Africa as anti-apartheid movement can
you describe what that experience was
like and and how it shaped your
political outlook I came from a family
in the background which was very
supportive of the apartheid philosophy
when I became a student and started
reading and thinking philosophically and
attending lectures I became for a few
years of Communists and that is
typically what you were if you were
staunchly anti-apartheid and a white or
European South African I knew all of the
leading figures the Mandela family the
tutu family and others something I'm
very proud of today that I was a
communist is a bit perplexing to me now
but it seemed to make sense at the time
where did that political evolution begin
well it was not some profound influence
like reading after Shrugged or Robert
Heinlein it was something more mundane
and actually for me much more important
I was a young legal clerk at that stage
and was walking out of our office to
deliver some documents or pleadings and
in the street near our building was a
little old lady who used to sit on the
side of the road finding fruit and
vegetables of fruit vender Street Linda
I saw her when I was walking along in
her direction leap happened ran away
around the corner and I couldn't
understand why and then next thing I saw
a police car pulled up
when policeman chased her around the
corner another ran up to her basket of
fruit and money and kicked it and that
went rolling across the road and I was
just appalled it was outrageous I
couldn't understand why nobody else was
I took the rest of the day off actually
got into a lot of trouble with my
employer over it and went down to the
police
and negotiated and protested and
arranged her release and I walked away
thinking to myself well that's
interesting because as a communist I
ought to be against her being able to be
a street trader that's what communism is
against and suddenly struck me that she
was actually a capitalist I regard her
as being the first capitalist I've ever
met and the first one who I admired and
the first one through his right side
decided to dedicate the rest of my life
fighting when you look at the rankings
of prosperity in different African
countries South Africa and usually
Botswana tend to rank near the top of
those lists is there anything that other
countries in the region can learn from
these two examples but SWANA is the
shining stories the extraordinary story
of the world frankly it has had the
highest growth rate averaged over the
last 30 years of any country in the
world a few people know that I think
it's China on Congo India or Singapore
somewhere but Swala
unlike most African countries never
adopted what was strangely called
African socialism a strange term because
socialism is of course an inherently
European idea was never part of African
tradition communalism was but it was a
great deal of personal freedom and
entrepreneurship and village markets
characterized Africa so Botswana
embarked right from the beginning on pro
market policies at a relatively free
economy by world standards and South
Africa did too under apartheid it was
clearly quite simple what South Africans
had one of the freest economies on earth
and black South Africans had one of the
most socialistic economies on earth one
of the closest things ever to the
elimination of class and under apartheid
and so what happened when there was
liberation for blacks is they largely
adopted the freedoms White's have which
meant South Africa rose on the economic
freedom indices and became something
like about the 40th freest economy on
earth but the even better news is that
the rest of Africa is privatizing
liberalizing democratizing and embarking
on classical liberal path of development
and is now the sub-saharan African
region
now the harsh grouse region in the world
what are a couple of the most important
reforms that have been pushing this
incredible growth and development
well liberalisation privatisation
Nigeria for example as announced the the
breakup of its nationalized centralized
electricity utility and a more important
one is the simple liberalisation of the
ability of people to start a small
business trading licenses and less
regulations take Rwanda for example an
extraordinary story amazing story
Starbucks now is buying much of its
coffee from arenda that was
inconceivable when it was one of the
most genocide or conflict ridden
backward pure places on earth the
President of Rwanda has instituted a
one-stop-shop system it is quick and
easy to go into business you don't deal
with more than one government agency it
sees to it that all of the other
requirements are met it's free and is
growing at very high growth rates so
it's the old story liberalizing and
privatizing it's not rocket science it's
not complicated it's everywhere it's
done it works it never fails the critics
of liberalisation or globalization often
say that there's exploitation going on
is Africa being exploited by the rest of
the world well the famous British
economist - regarded herself as a
socialist Joan Robinson said there's
only one worse thing than being
exploited and it's not being exploited
and so yes it is being exploited thank
goodness people are exploiting Africa by
buying things from it by investing in it
by employing people in it and the worst
thing that would happen is if people's
decide to stop exploiting Africa this
word exploitation is very strange it
means taking advantage of a situation
and it's premise the negative
implication is premised on an assumption
that if I exploit you or you exploit me
and we both reduce we both participate
in that exploitation voluntarily that
one of us is somehow worse off because
the other one is better or for that's
clearly nonsense is economic inequality
going to be a problem for Africa the
world has just experienced in his
experience
the most extraordinary phenomenon that
has ever happened in the world the most
amazing accomplishment of humanity is
the virtual elimination of poverty and
it's strange that as that happens we are
talking about it as if there's more of
it and this is simply not so so rising
income inequality is using old-fashioned
econometric ways of measuring something
namely how much money you have or the
value of capital that you have or assets
but economists have never claimed that
this is telling you much about the
quality of life the poor use to live 20
21 25 years and on our they're in their
living standards are rising such access
to medical care food proper housing safe
water and so on to the point where they
are now living 65 70 years and age life
expectancies conflating for the rich and
the poor that's probably the single most
important indicator that in fact is
declining inequality the amenities of
life for the poor the access to
motorised transport to
telecommunications to medical care to
painkillers to food to education one
aspect of Africa's economy that's gotten
a fair amount of press in the 21st
century is the rise of the
telecommunications industry there and
you see pictures of Africans and what
appeared to be very poor villages
holding cell phone have you observed the
mobile technology revolution in Africa
and and what effect has it had there
I've traveled around for example in some
of the remotest parts of planet Earth a
Maasai Mara and south western Kenya for
example in northeastern Tanzania
Northwest in Tanzania and there you see
the iconic Messiah herdsmen in a red
blanket with a Nessa guy in one hand
herding some goats and a cellphone in
the other hand and they no longer carry
cash trader on the side of the road
under a tree will transfer the money
from when mobile phone to another in a
way that even Americans are not yet
doing you've actually said that digital
currencies like Bitcoin might be one of
the most important developments going
forward why do you feel that way so
being able to buy and sell and transfer
freely from one part of the world to
another without being watched or known
or documented is one of the great
Liberation's that the world might
experience without knowing the term all
the technology friedrich hayek i
consider myself more Hayekian than iock
predicted something like this in his
book the d nationalization of money
which was that they should be completely
non government money and had he known
about the technology for cryptocurrency
I'm quite sure that would have excited
him a great deal as a Nobel
prize-winning economist
Leon Lowe thank you very much for
talking to us my pleasure
for reason TV I'm Zack Weissmuller